zombies have been an essential presence
in film
ever since night of the living dead
released in 1968
but they found serious mainstream appeal
in the past several decades
here are some 21st century masterpieces
that fans of all things undead can't
afford to miss
before he got his hand full of oscars
for slumdog millionaire british director
danny boyle grabbed audiences attention
with 2002's 28 days later which stars
kylian murphy is a man who awakens from
a coma
and finds himself in an abandoned london
both the protagonists and the audience
are thrust right into a world turned
upside down
one that's full of violent monsters that
have been infected with the absolutely
named rage virus
even more frightening than the
relentless zombies however other greedy
humans who find themselves going mad
with their newfound power
although boyle would go on to direct
slow burning dramas based on real life
like 127 hours and steve jobs
28 days later showed off his ability to
direct grizzly horror
at great next speed grimy yet intimate
cinematography and
emotional supporting performances from
naomi harris and brendan gleason
made for an experience such as roars and
meat that zombies love to consume
even considering all of the other
impressive movies boyle has helmed in
the decades since its release
28 days later still remains one of his
finest creations
as well as an essential and influential
film in the 21st century canon of zombie
cinema
short of the dead may not be the first
film to lovingly parody zombie cinema
but it's certainly one of the funniest
edgar wright's second feature film was
his first to feature the dynamic duo of
simon pegg and nick frost
a combination that has proven its worth
time and time again
with projects like the movie hot fuzz
and the tv show
spaced this hilarious story about the
last people to learn about the zombie
apocalypse
showcases right british sense of humor
impeccable comedic timing
and trademark energy behind the camera
filled with quotable lines and recurring
gags
the banter between shawn and his friends
is a breath of fresh air
in a genre so often filled with nothing
but doom and gloom
what's the matter david i'm taking a
shortcut before
charming critics and audiences alike
sean of the dead proved itself to be a
21st century comedy classic
not only did it kick off the iconic
cornetto trilogy that continued with hot
furs in the world's end but it also
established right as a filmmaker to
watch
and set a new standard for not just
zombie movies but for comedies in
general
not too shabby for a rookie director in
the wake of twilight making serious cash
at the box office
it was only a matter of time before more
human monster romances
made their way to the silver screen one
of these films was 2013's warm bodies
which swapped out sparkling vampires for
shambling zombies
however viewers expecting just another
twilight knockoff were in for a surprise
as director jonathan levine managed to
imbue the film with more heart and soul
than anyone
expected a movie about reanimated
corpses to have
rather than delivering what might be
considered realistic visions of how the
infected might look and act
warm bodies revels in the awkward oddity
of classic zombies the ones that eat
brains
move slow and can barely speak this
makes for plenty of fun comedy and some
unexpectedly heartfelt moments when a
walking corpse falls head over rotting
heels for a human woman
after defending her from several of his
undead compatriots
totally committed lead performances from
nicholas holtz and teresa palmer
helped deliver a movie romance that's
more than a little off the beaten path a
relationship that you can't help but
root for this
romeo and juliet story is filled with
hearts whether that's hard as beating or
not
in the late 2000s nearly a decade after
the blair witch project brought found
footage into the mainstream
the genre saw a major resurgence with
films like the low budget supernatural
thriller paranormal activity and the
mysterious kaiju feature cloverfield
this trend wasn't limited just to
america though as spain delivered its
own unique spin on the zombie genre with
the incredibly freaky
wreck the film follows a reporter who
accompanies a group of firemen to an
emergency at an apartment building where
a zombie outbreak has recently begun
only to find themselves locked inside by
the authorities with nowhere to escape
directors helmet balaguerro and parco
plaza
use the found footage formats not just
as a way to keep production costs down
but rather as a way to immerse audiences
in a world of frightening uncertainty
the brazenly chilling imagery throughout
wreck
ensured that it couldn't be mistaken for
any other zombie flick at the time
embedding itself in the viewers minds
like an axe to the head
the box office success of rex spawns not
only a sequel
but an american remake in the form of
the 2008 motion picture quarantine
however quarantine impressed far fewer
critics than the first spanish film
and more than a decade later it's still
the original wreck that's keeping movie
goers up at night with its bold approach
to found footage filmmaking
it's easy to imagine a version of
zombielands that's just an american
remake of shaun of the dead but this
2009 comedy feature was able to
establish its own identity
on the backs of its many iconic
performances jesse eisenberg's neuronic
everyman
woody harrelson's thrill-seeking badass
and emma stone and abigail breslin's
wisecracking con artist sisters
make up an eccentric zombie survival
squad thus as good at busting guts as
they are at busting hordes of the undead
director ruben flyshaw gives zombieland
plenty of unique flourishes that make it
stand out in the increasingly crowded
world of zombie cinema
these include memorable rules for
survival a colorful climax and an
amusement park and of course an
unforgettable cameo from bill murray as
himself
so do you have any regrets
garfield maybe with this many laughs
it's no wonder that zombieland
cultivated a fanbase so devoted that it
got a sequel an entire decade after its
release in zombieland double tap
much like the walking dead zombieland
refuses to die
and it's not hard to see why comedy is
this good a rarer than a twinkie in the
apocalypse
looking for a zombie movie to watch for
the whole family the options may be
scarce but paranorman proves her out
there
the second film from leica studios
paranorman is the offbeat story of
norman
a kid who can see ghosts and follows his
quest to save his small town from
puritan zombies and the witch's curse
the project may not be as intense as
your typical zombie flick
but it shouldn't surprise anyone
familiar with leica's infamously creepy
first feature coraline that there's no
shortage of scares here
regardless of age rating the zombies and
ghosts in paranorman aren't just here
for the frights though
they help tell a delightful story about
friendship acceptance and what makes all
of us unique
each frame is lovingly crafted with
leica's impressive stop-motion animation
which lends a signature tactile quality
to everything from a zombie's dangling
jaw to a smear of nail polish
paranorman is a film that's equal parts
chilling and thoughtful
and its overwhelming heart has made it
one of the more critically acclaimed
animated movies
of the 21st century this insightful take
on the genre is perfect for
horror-loving parents who want to get
their children in on the action from a
young age
zombie movies have been used as a means
for providing social commentary since
night of the living dead
a trend that continued into 2020 with
jeff varmedy's blood quantum
in this film as a zombie apocalypse
spreads across north america
the native residents of a first nations
reserve finds themselves strangely
immune from the infection
unfortunately for them there's no such
thing as immunity from getting torn to
shreds
so three generations must work together
to navigate the new and dead status quo
and save as many people as they possibly
can throughout its run time blood
quantum offers ruminations on
experiences specific to indigenous
individuals who rarely find themselves
in heroic leading roles in mainstream
film
excellent performances by indigenous
actors michael grahas
forrest goodluck and stonehorse lone
goemon made for an undeniably harrowing
viewing experience
despite a rocky release and mixed public
reception
blood quantum received overwhelmingly
positive marks from critics
with roxanna haddadi from bajiber
praising it takes aim at colonization
and the subjugation of native and
indigenous peoples
and barnaby is wrapping those
considerations in writhing coils of
intestines
and splattering them with a hot burst of
arterial blood
the combination of social commentary and
blood-soaked carnage
makes blood quantum more than just an
entertaining thrill ride
it's also an exciting expansion on the
kind of themes that zombie movies can
explore
one cut of the dead is in a word
ingenious this japanese zombie comedy
revels in its twists and turns but even
without spoiling its big surprises
it's easy to say that director
shinichiro ueda
displays a level of creativity never
before seen in the shamrock when a crew
making a low budget zombie flick is
attacked by actual
real-life zombies their unhinged
director demands that they keep the
camera rolling for maximum authenticity
putting everyone around him in mortal
danger in order to get that one perfect
shot
as actors and crew members fight for
their lives the camera shows the action
in a single extended take
capturing the chaos in real time ueda
does impressive work handling the shift
from a casual hangout vibe to all hell
breaking loose or without ever taking a
single break in the action
keep watching after the credits though
because nothing in this movie is quite
what it seems
at once a rollercoaster ride and an
exercise in unearthing death in even the
most unexpected places the sense of
creativity and one cut of the dead is
very much a life
a christmas zombie musical might sound
like a mismatched mess
but sana on the apocalypse not only
proves that it can be done but that it
can be done well
this yuletide tale following anna and
her high school friends as they try to
navigate a sudden zombie apocalypse
works precisely because it leans
completely into everything that makes it
unique
transporting audiences into a campy
world full of festive frights
just because this is a musical doesn't
mean the zombies are any less menacing
though anna in the apocalypse doesn't
skimp on the blood and gore
especially when ana's signature candy
cane weapon is involved the musical
numbers aren't lacking either
tunes like hollywood ending and soldier
at war are sure to stay stuck in your
head even long after the credits roll
anna in the apocalypse isn't smashing
together genres to make
some belabor punchline its affection for
every type of storytelling it lampoons
is both evident and endearing
like so many culinary treats anna in the
apocalypse is what happens when you get
something magical
out of fusing together things aren't
typically paired up
zombies on a train might sound a silly
an idea as snakes on a plane but that's
the central conceit behind train to
busan
one of the greatest zombie movies not
just of the 21st century
but of all time writer park giuseok and
director yun sang ho
trap a packed cast of characters into
the cramped confines of a train that
suddenly becomes infested with hordes of
the undead
the passengers must move beyond barriers
of class and age and work as a team in
order to survive their perilous journey
to the coastal city
of busan well trained to busan will
certainly give any zombie lover their
fill of undead carnage it's the humanity
of its living protagonists that truly
makes it shine
the characters in train to busan are
memorable and lovable
especially mardum suk's character yoon
sanghwa a charismatic tough guy with the
heart of gold
who takes down zombies with his fists
with such engaging figures to ground the
story
train to busan makes audiences cry
rather than chia when characters meet
their untimely ends
who knew the key to creating a floral
zombie movie was simply putting them on
public transportation
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite films are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one